[Musique]
le département de la réunion présente
officiellement son nouveau dispositif
d'insertion pour les personnes
bénéficiaires du rsa
le r + ou l'allocation d'insertion et de
retour à l'emploi
celui qui est bénéficiaire du rsa qui
veut aller vers une formation
qualifiante qui veut créer son
entreprise qui veut aller vers un emploi
dans le domaine agricole dans le domaine
de l'aide à la personne
dans le domaine économique eh bien ces
personnes pourront aller vers cette
association durable sans pour autant
perdre le bénéfice de leur allocation le
r + vise une intégration professionnelle
durable des bénéficiaires du rsa
ce dispositif garantit la compensation
totale des pertes d'allocations du
bénéficiaire
tout au long de son parcours d'insertion
le r + garantit ainsi une sécurité
financière avec ea plus vous gardez vos
allocations et vous allez cumuler leurs
revenus du travail salarié en formation
etc
donc c'est un cumul entre la location
qui se maintient au même niveau et les
revenus de l'activité
et c'est une garantie de maintien des
droits sociaux le département compte
ainsi accompagner 5000 bénéficiaires des
minima sociaux
le pôle emploi et la caisse
d'allocations familiales sont les
partenaires de ce dispositif est
conseillé insertion des cinq territoires
d'action sociale du département
assureront également l'accompagnement
des bénéficiaires
rr plus ce n'est pas seulement de verser
une allocation t parental financier à
tous les mois c'est l'accompagnement
donc ils vont repérer ces publics les
informer ses opportunités offertes par
les quatre levées qui sont prévus dans
le cadre ci faire plus et lorsque ces
personnes sont inscrites dans ce
dispositif faire plus tous les trois
mois il y aura des entretiens qui vont
être réalisés et s'agissant de la
création d'activités tous les six mois
une vraie possibilité de réviser le
montant dû être plus si vous êtes au rsa
depuis plus de six mois et que vous
souhaitez reprendre une activité
professionnelle par l'insertion par la
formation par la mobilité ou encore par
la création d'entreprise le r +
s'adresse à vous il garantira vos
revenus pour vous permettre de réussir
votre insertion et décrocher un emploi
durable
[Musique]